our our next speaker is segue levine uh
it's
uh who's at berkeley in the department
of electrical
engineering computer science he's a phd
grad from computer science at stanford
so and
he works at the intersection of control
and uh machine learning so it's a
nice theme for this week and uh
and he's a great uh um publicist for the
field
with lots of uh media coverage of his
work
in places like new york times and i mean
you know and
bloomberg business okay
all right thank you very much for the
introduction um so
uh for today's talk um what i thought
about what
talk about since i'm coming in kind of
at the end of the of a week-long
workshop on this topic i figured
you know so much has already been
covered that i should pick something a
little different
uh to hopefully keep people entertained
um
so i decided i'd make this it's a little
bit of a frankenstein kind of talk it
has
somewhat distinct parts stitched
together but i want to do that because i
actually want to point
out some similarities maybe these
similarities are kind of obvious to a
lot of you
between what what might conventionally
be seen as two fairly different topics
uh offline reinforcement learning and
model based optimization and
um i wish i had uh i wish i could tell
you that
these ideas and some really interesting
way to develop a better algorithm i
haven't actually done that yet
so i'm just going to talk about the two
parts separately but hopefully
i'll present it in a way that will make
the connections obvious and maybe you
can figure out how to combine them
uh to get much better algorithms so you
know don't expect me to tell you
how model based optimization can
revolutionize offline or all because
i haven't done that work yet uh but
that's kind of the point of a workshop
like this is to
kind of stir up some of these ideas all
right so
uh and don't worry if you don't know
what model-based optimization means i'll
describe it in a very biased way in a
second
uh but to start with uh let's start with
kind of a
a somewhat big question and a simplistic
answer
what makes modern machine learning work
uh well
maybe at a very very high level what
makes modern machine learning work
is the availability of very large data
sets and
very large and high capacity models so
we've seen that this basic recipe works
really well in a range of supervised
learning fields like
image recognition translation
speech recognition and so on so
maybe you know as long as we have large
data sets and large models we can get
things working well
and we've seen that predictive models
trained in this way can be very powerful
not just
for you know computer vision and lp but
also domains
that might more conventionally be viewed
as decision making domains for instance
uh you know this is a paper from fair
from facebook ai research
on predicting the uh functional
properties of proteins
all right so uh this often
goes hand in hand with decision making
problems like maybe you want to select
or design a protein to do something
they're not doing that in this paper
they're just
predicting the properties but the
insinuation is that if you could train
these predictive models you could
perhaps
design proteins to do something and
those of you that heard about the recent
results from deep mind and protein
folding
kind of similar story a big part of why
people care about that problem
is not because they want to solve the
prediction problem they want to
solve the decision-making problem of
selecting a design that
has a particular functionality or a
particular geometry
another data point work on
uh medical imaging right so medical
imaging
is in service to a decision-making
problem the point of doing medical
imaging is to make a decision about what
treatment to administer
now in the academic world the research
in this area is more concerned with can
you actually make an accurate prediction
can you you know take an x-ray
of someone and predict whether they have
pneumonia very timely very topical
thing these days but you know the reason
people are excited about this is because
it's eventually going to be in service
to decision making
but these this is all work on predictive
model there's no decision making
actually being done
in in these works
there's also work on decision making
separately from this in the community
and we've seen that automated decision
making is of course very powerful
everyone here is
familiar with this uh that you can set
up a reinforcement learning algorithm
that can play
video games control robots and beat
world champions that go so one might
hope that somehow these these things can
be combined and you could have
reinforcement learning algorithms
that can uh you know diagnose people
with pneumonia and
decide on a course of treatment or
design uh you know proteins to act as
drugs or what have you
so the obvious question is can we put
these ideas together
and can we make things work really well
so can we actually use the model that we
trained in this way with reinforcement
learning for things like you know
courses of treatment for patients
designing drugs what have you and
controlling robots
so what could possibly go wrong what's
what's the problem with uh
with this notion well um
there are two problem settings that i'm
going to outline and i'm going to
claim that these problem settings are
actually very deeply related then i'll
describe a problem
that they have in common and then i'll
describe some algorithms that as i said
before unfortunately
address these two problems in isolation
but hopefully are suggestive of ways to
put them together so the first setting
is
uh offline reinforcement learning so uh
conventional reinforcement learning is
is viewed as an on policy process where
you have an agent interacts with the
world
collects some data improves its policy
and then it interacts with the world
some more
off policy rl extends this to the
setting where you store
previous data offline rl extends it
further
to the setting where you just you're
just given some data like in a
conventional
supervised machine learning problem and
then you're going to use that data that
you've been given
to learn a policy and this makes a lot
of sense if you're imagining something
like
uh you know prescribing course of
treatment for patients because you don't
want to do
on policy exploration in that setting
but you could perhaps obtain a lot of
data
from you know human doctors that have
prescribed courses of treatment
and use that historical data to learn
policies all right
the second setting is data-driven
model-based optimization and i'm going
to claim
this is very very closely related so
this is a setting where
uh there's some true underlying function
that maps inputs
x to outputs y uh and x is some
representation of a design something
that you'd like to obtain maybe it is a
protein sequence or it is
the uh you know a molecule for a drug
or is the parameters of an aircraft wing
something that you're trying to select
to attain some some score so y
represents how good that is you know how
fast does the airplane fly
how well does the drug treat the patient
things like that
and you know we could imagine sort of
approaching this problem
a little bit naively to say well let's
get a data set of
uh you know designs and their efficacies
let's get a data set let's say proteins
and how how well they they do it binding
to a particular
receptor take the designs as x
the efficacy says why and train a model
you know those predictive models those
wonderful predictive models that
facebook and uh uh and others have
designed
can we just train those up and then
let's
uh optimize with respect to x
right so we're gonna train them up with
an empirical risk minimization and then
select the x
that maximizes uh the learned model f
hat theta x
uh you know for the many of you might
already be guessing what the connection
to reinforcement learning is if you just
replace
f with q and x with a you're basically
in the reinforcement learning setting
so what could possibly go wrong these
are very similar problems
and they share very similar challenges
so you can think of offline model based
optimization as basically offline rl
with high dimensional bandits right so
you know the word the word bandit is
probably
the the uh the correct way to make that
connection
all right so the problem uh the the
major problem that at least
i've noticed when trying to work on the
on these issues
is the distributional shift you get as a
result of optimization
so uh if we have our our protein problem
or our drug design problem or our
aircraft design problem
the problem of finding the best design
involves taking the r
max of some learned function and taking
the arg max of a learned function when
that function is some highly expressive
thing like a deep neural network
is known in the community to be a really
terrible idea
uh right so we train this function with
empirical risk minimization the way we
train anything
uh it'll work well on uh designs sampled
from the training set
or from the training distribution rather
but then we could ask well is the
probability under the training
distribution of the optimized design of
the arc max of x star is that going to
be high
probably not because we know that what
can happen and what does happen
with large high capacity models as
adversarial examples
if you optimize an input to get a
desired output
you're going to basically be fooling
your network you're going to be finding
uh an input on which the network makes
the largest mistake in the positive
direction and we know that such inputs
exist they exist for virtually all
high-capacity models and they're called
that are several examples so in a sense
this process of
taking this arcmaps it's virtually
identical to the process people use to
synthesize adversarial examples
so adversarial examples are what you're
going to get when you do this and it's
perhaps
most obvious if you imagine that x is
high dimensional like an image
but the same basic principle will hold
even for lower dimensional axis
and certainly it'll hold for things like
you know protein sequences
so optimizing respect to model input
might just optimize for the biggest
mistake in fact
i would probably revise and say not
might but will
so what i'll talk about today uh is the
following i'll discuss how
we can uh you know the kind of
challenges that we get in offline rl
that basically reflect
this uh distribution shift due to
optimization how we can mitigate this
challenge
in the sequential reinforcement learning
setting with an algorithm called
conservative q learning
and how we can mitigate it in the model
based optimization setting
with an algorithm called model inversion
networks and these
algorithms are different but hopefully
what what this will prompt you to think
about is
whether there's some crosstalk that's
possible here or algorithms in one
domain
can inform solutions in the other but
let's
briefly talk about you know a little
more concretely about
how this optimization distribution shift
issue actually crops up
in reinforcement learning so hopefully i
don't have to go through the
primer on rl you know if you're in this
workshop i'm sure you're very familiar
with this
you want to maximize expected reward a
very useful thing for maximize
expected reward is the q function uh
because once you have a q function you
can recover the greedy policy
and an optimal q function satisfies the
optimal bellman equation
uh which means that you just have to
make the left-hand side of this thing be
equal to the right-hand side
which we often do by solving some kind
of regression problem so
regress your qsa onto your target values
which are rsa plus max over the next q
right standard q learning
um and this talk is going to focus
basically on entirely dynamic
programming i know there's a
world out there that is not dynamic
programming that i'm just going to
ignore
but that's because i have a limited time
so we're going to be doing q learning
um all right so what's the problem with
q learning in the offline setting
uh we ran some experiments uh you know
we're a very experimental group so we
don't we don't believe in uh
just uh uh you know just the theoretical
analysis we want to see for ourselves
so we tried to see for ourselves and
indeed uh there was a problem
uh this is some work from about a year
ago where we wanted to see what happens
if you run
in this case it's actually an actor
critic algorithm but it's very similar
to q learning algorithm it's just an
actor critic with a q function
what happens when you actually train uh
in the in the offline setting
and we were getting bad results and in
particular we saw that the longer we
train the worse the results get so we
did what any
uh reasonable machine learning person
will do and we surmise we must be over
fitting
so we tried offline rl with different
size data sets this is the half cheetah
benchmark
blue is 1000 transitions the red is one
million transitions
and they're both equally bad so if it
was overfitting you'd expect it to get
better as you increase the amount of
data and it doesn't uh when we
interrogate the q function to ask it how
well it thinks
it's doing it thinks it's doing great so
the y axis here is a log scale
that red line the one million data
points is at ten to the seventh power
so it thinks it's going to do really
really well and then it's sorely
disappointed when it's actually used
to control the system so what's going on
why does it think it's going to do so
well
and end up doing so poorly well this is
that distribution shift problem
and to understand a little bit more
detail
uh you know we have to recognize that
what we're solving when we fit the q
function is
empirical risk minimization it's
empirical risk minimization
under a particular training distribution
p of x and if we train f
under p of x and we're given some x star
we can ask is
f theta of x star going to be correct f
theta is whatever we're learning q
function
model etc um well we know that the
empirical error
under the training distribution is going
to be low
but the expected error under some other
distribution p bar is in general not
going to be low if p bar is not equal to
p
and even if x star comes from p of x
even then the error is not guaranteed to
be low because we're not minimizing
point wise there we're minimizing
expected error
now uh you know the the deep learning
practitioner might say at this point
the caricature of a deep learning
practitioner might say well we don't
worry about this because neural nets
generalize
uh so you know eu statisticians will
make a fuss about distributional shift
but we've got neural nets and they
generalize uh
and actually they often do but there's a
bigger problem here
because we're not just going to be
evaluating f of theta of x on an outer
distribution input
we're going to be selecting that input
to be the r max of f theta of x
and here's a picture to hopefully
convince you that this is bad if you
didn't believe my adversarial example
point from before
let's say that this green curve is your
true function and the blue curve
is the fit that you learned for that
function the blue curve is
not too bad like it's actually pretty
decent in most places but if you select
the r max
you get precisely that point that has
the largest positive error
so even if you generalize well even if
you have a good model
if you're picking your input with an r
max you're going to get into trouble
and where does that crop up in queue
learning well let's rewrite the bellman
equation a slightly different way
instead instead of writing it as a max
i'll write it as the expected value of
the
of the next q value under a distribution
pi nu
where pi nu is an r max so i didn't
actually change anything i just wrote it
in a different way that made it a little
clearer
that you're evaluating an expected value
so that's your target value that's your
y and how do you train q well you train
it
to minimize error in expectation under
your behavior policy which i've denoted
here is pi beta
so you're regressing onto your target
values under pi beta
so you would expect to get good accuracy
when pi beta
is equal to pi nu right because then you
don't have distributional shift
but of course the whole point is to
improve over pi betas to get a policy
that's better than whoever collected
your data
so pi data will not be equal to pi nu
and even worse pi nu is going to be
selected to maximize this expected value
so that's exactly the bad thing that we
talked about on the previous slide
and that's why we get this massive
overestimation we're selecting the
policy
to maximize the q values which is
essentially finding an adversarial
example
for our q function
all right so how has prior work gone
about trying to mitigate this
um well one way that people have
approached this problem with
some success is to constrain pi new to
say well
i'm going to not just pick pi new to
maximize the q value
i'm going to pick it to be within some
interval of pi data
and that's a very reasonable thing to do
the solved distributional shift doesn't
mean you get no more erroneous values
well sort of but there are still a few
issues uh that said this
method has been quite popular it's you
know it's a fairly old idea to impose
policy constraints of this sort going
back to
natural writing and things like that uh
but there are quite a few papers more
recently that'll explore this idea
it does have two issues one issue is
that this might be way too conservative
the reason it might be way too
conservative is you know imagine for a
minute that pi beta
has very broad support maybe it's just
even a totally random policy
now constraining your pi to be close to
a totally random policy means you just
don't allow the agent
to be too deterministic that kind of
seems like a bad idea if you have broad
coverage
that broad that data with broad coverage
probably supports a much better policy
than a totally random one so this can be
way too conservative
it can be partially mitigated with
things like support constraints
essentially instead of
constraining the distributions to be
close you can constrain their supports
to be close and that can really help
but it doesn't fully address the issue
the second issue is that estimating the
behavior policy itself
for the sake of enforcing this
constraint can also be difficult
so if if your data was collected in a
you know synthetic experiment by another
reinforcement learning agent
then getting pi data might be pretty
easy but if you're talking about the
medical
you know treatment setting where the
data was like human doctors doing stuff
you know you don't know what policy they
were employing and just copying their
behavior with a
uh by fitting a policy by beta might
already be pretty challenging
so this can be a serious uh issue in
practice and again it can be partially
mitigated there's some
tricks like for example you can have
implicit constraints that don't require
knowing the functional form of pi beta
but only require samples and those can
work to a degree but it's still a
challenge
so what i'm going to talk about next is
an algorithm that perhaps more directly
attacks
the cause of the problem the
distribution shift
due to optimization and this is an
algorithm called conservative q learning
so the problem is that we have this
massive overestimation because we're
essentially optimizing against our q
function and fooling it
into thinking that we can get a high
value so that's this problem
and the way we're going to mitigate it
is pretty directly we're going to take
our original
uh you know fitting objective for our q
function and we'll combine it with a
regularizer
that explicitly finds the q values the
the actions with high key values
and pushes them down so in this
regularizer there's an action
distribution mu
that is selected adversarially and the q
values are
minimized under mu so the whole point is
to basically find these peaks
and push them down it's a it's a very
blunt instrument it's a pretty direct
way to just directly find
those erroneously high q values and
drive them down so they're not so high
anymore
now this blunt instrument can actually
be shown to learn a lower bound on the
true q function
if you choose the regularizing parameter
alpha appropriately
so you can show that if you learn q hat
pi in this way it'll be
pointwise less than or equal to the true
q pi under some technical assumptions
for a large enough alpha
and that suggests a pretty
straightforward algorithm for doing
offline rl
simply alternate between learning your
lower bound q function
and improving your policy to maximize
that lower bound
and then hopefully you wouldn't
overestimate
now the bound can actually be improved
substantially if you're just driving
down the large q values you're going to
drive down the q
values that are mistakenly large you'll
also drive down the ones that are
correctly large
so there's a more nuanced bound that
tends to work a lot better
and the idea is to take this term that
always pushes the q values down
and add a second term that pushes them
up so notice here there's a negative
sign
the q values are pushed down under mu
which is selected to find the large q
values
and they're pushed up under the data
distribution so the idea is that if your
large q values
are for actions that are similar to
actions in the data set these two terms
should cancel out so the the in
distribution action should not get
pushed down
but if you have large q values for out
of distribution actions then the first
term will push them down
and the second term will push something
else up
now it's actually no longer guaranteed
if you use a subjective
that you will get a point wise bound
however
somewhat surprisingly we can still show
that you get a bound in expectation
under your policy
which means that you're bounding the
value function
so you still get you still get the
result of if you learn your q function
in this way the resulting value function
will be a lower bound on the true value
function for a large enough alpha
so you minimize the big q values
maximize the q values in the data set
the full statement of the theorem that's
in the paper is shown here it's a little
bit involved but
let me just briefly summarize
essentially three terms we're saying
that v
hat the learned value function is less
than or equal to the true value function
minus alpha times some positive
pessimism term due to the regularizer
plus an error term due to sampling error
and alpha just needs to be chosen large
enough
so that this pessimism term overpowers
the sampling error term
and if that's the case then you get a
lower bound
okay so does the bound hold in practice
uh
we measured this empirically so the
numbers that i'm going to show you are
the expected value of the learned q
function
with cql minus the monte carlo estimate
of the true q function so if these
numbers are negative that means that
we're underestimating if they're
positive
then we're overestimating uh and here
are the results so cqlh
is the final method that i showed cql
equation one that's the initial method
that just has the minimization
and you can see that both of the cql
variants give lower bounds although the
more advanced
version gives a much tighter bound and
then most of the prior methods things
like ensembles and
policy constraints actually are still
wildly optimistic in comparison
we evaluated this on a range of uh
benchmark tasks from the the d4 rl data
set so d4rl is a
data set for evaluating deep offline rl
methods that we devised
that has you know tasks like maze
navigation that requires stitching
together parts of different trajectories
more realistic robotics tasks like
dexterous manipulation
as well as some driving and traffic
control tasks so
if you're interested in evaluating your
offline rl methods i highly recommend
this is getting to be a pretty popular
data set
um when we looked at how cql compares to
prior methods and this was done back in
may so better methods have come out
since then
but at least back in may when we tried
this one of the things we found was that
you know for some of the harder tasks
like the am the maze navigation requires
stitching together parts of trajectories
most of the previous methods things like
these policy constraint methods
really didn't work very well so these
scores are normalized between 0 and 100.
on some of the robotics tasks the
strongest baseline was actually just
behavior cloning the data set so
that means that the the rl part of the
offline url just wasn't helping all that
much
cql by comparison actually did very well
across the range of these tasks
up to five times better on some of the
dexterous manipulation tasks
fifty to three hundred percent better on
some of the others
um and you know in a sense infinitely
better on the maze tasks because it was
the only method that was able to
make some progress same story in atari
games so it seems like it works quite
well across many of these tasks
and we also seem to have some idea for
why it works because of this lower bound
property
of course there's still plenty of room
for improvement as i said these scores
are normalized between 0 and 100
so there's still a really long way to go
all right so i talked a little bit about
how we can have this minimization trick
to
address the issue of optimism that
occurs because we're optimizing against
our learned function
next let me talk a little bit about
model based optimization where i'll
describe a different approach
but hopefully it'll be apparent how
these these different methods
might be applicable to both domains all
right
so here we're going to be dealing with
uh predictive modeling and design so
the the setup we're concerned with we
collect data from previous trials
data consists of tuples of x and y we
learn a mapping from x to y
and then we're going to use that mapping
to find the best x so if this is a q
function we would be doing rl but we're
just going to be doing design
we could optionally collect more data
but we're going to focus on the fully
offline case here
so what's wrong with just doing
prediction well uh you know i've
mentioned this before but
uh you know essentially the problem is
that when you optimize your new design
to find the rmax of the learn function
you might get another distribution input
or an adversarial example
uh so you know we can illustrate this
like this let's say the x-axis is your
design
maybe it's your protein uh this is the
true function f of x and there's it's
optimum
uh you get a data set maybe the data set
is represented by these green dots
you fit your function to those green
dots and you hope that you get something
like this
so you hope that your fitted function f
hat theta has the same optimum as the
true function
and then when you optimize it you know
instead of optimizing the true function
which you don't know you optimize f hat
theta of x which you do know
and hopefully your design
you know is close enough to your data
set that you get the correct answer
but if your f hat theta of x
extrapolates or generalizes in some
unreasonable way
then the art max might be very far from
a good design and it might actually have
very bad performance so you somehow need
to keep
your design close to your data so
somehow you need to
figure out this region where you can
trust your function and stay in that
region
all right so can we somehow maybe
estimate the training data distribution
and stay close to that training data
distribution this would be the
equivalent of a policy constraint method
in offline rl but now apply to this
design problem
it turns out that this is actually very
hard to do in high dimensions
in fact if your learned function f hat
theta of x is susceptible to adversarial
examples
your learned density estimator can also
be susceptible to adversarial examples
so there's a paper called do deep
generative models know what they don't
know
the short answer is no uh and this is a
quote from the paper we find that the
density learned by flow based models vas
and pixel cnns
cannot distinguish images of common
objects such as dogs trucks and horses
from those of house numbers assigning a
higher likelihood of the latter
when trained on the former so it's not a
great idea to use density models to
estimate these
these confidence regions because the
density models themselves can be fooled
so what can we do well
we would like to maximize f theta of x
subject to a constraint that our x's
are in distribution but this is hard
because x's are very high dimensional
and it's easy to find invalid x's that
will fool our density
right it's easy to find these
adversarial examples
but here's an interesting observation
our output y
is one dimensional so finding valid
values of y
is very easy if you have a
one-dimensional uh
variable you can just discretize it and
just see where you have higher density
and that's very easy
you can't fool that because it's so low
dimensional
so what if instead of learning f hat
theta of x we learn
uh f inverse of y instead of mapping
from x to y
we learn from we learn to map from y to
x
and then we can find in distribution y's
very easily because y is just a scalar
value
so then we're going to select x star to
be f hat
inverse of y for the largest y that is
close to the data
and that can help us alleviate this
distributional shift problem
it's still tricky to choose the y that
is close to the data but it's much
easier than before because y is just a
scalar value
so we call this model inversion networks
because they aim to invert the model
all right so
one problem here is that f inverse of y
is one to many in general for any given
fitness value there might be multiple
designs
that attain that fitness value so we're
going to approximate f inverse of y
with actually a stochastic function
we're gonna have a neural net that takes
in the y
and also a noise sample z and the idea
is that for different z's you'd out with
different x's
so for a given base distribution over z
we want to cover
all the x's that take on that value of y
so z is just a random number and
uh the way that we're going to train
this thing is well we need a generative
model that turns random z's into x's
and turns out the gans do exactly this
so generator vaporiser networks that
take in noise
they output a sample from your data
distribution and we're just going to
train
a conditional general adversarial
network so these are great for
generating faces
they've also been sure to generate
things like proteins and other more
relevant things for this discussion
so we're going to choose uh x-star
we're going to train at f inverse uh as
it began
so it's going to be a function that
takes in y and z and we'll choose x star
by just asking our f inverse of y to
generate the x for the largest y that's
close to the day
now a simple way to choose why would be
to choose the best one in the data set
and then slightly increase it
but we have we can do a little bit
better if we choose y such that an
inverse and forward model agree with
each other
so we'll actually optimize over both y
and also z
the noise to find the largest y
so that when you take your y feed it
into f inverse and then feed it back
into your learned f
you get back the same y
so you're going to maximize that subject
the constraint that the y
that you start out with and the y they
get from you know
inverting it and then sending it back
forward agree with each other that are
within epsilon that will give you in
distribution y's
that are hopefully as large as your data
set will support
and since the y is 1d and all the z's
are in distribution because that's just
your base noise distribution
this is all okay to do so you're not
going to generate adversarial examples
by doing this
because y is 1d and all the z's are in
distribution because it's just noise
so putting it all together we take our
data set we train an inverse model with
a gan
we train a forward model with just mean
squared error
we find the y and the z where the
forward and inverse models agree with
each other
and that's our final design uh i'll go
pretty quickly through experimental
results since i don't have
very much time but we applied this to
you know protein design tasks
borrow from paper by brooks at all where
this thing works pretty well it can also
generate faces
so in the face generation experiment the
goal is to generate the youngest face
so you've only seen faces that are older
than 15 years of age and it's trying to
generate the youngest face and you know
the faces
look a little messed up but uh in
subjective human studies
humans do rate these as being younger
than the youngest face in the data set
so it seems to be applicable to high
dimensional problems like faces
as well as more relevant problems like
protein design
but the bit that i want to talk about
very briefly at the end is a little bit
of takeaways
so i talked about how data driven
optimization can handle these high
dimensional design spaces but simple
predictive models are not enough because
of that optimism uh issue
effective data-driven optimization
requires some mechanism to account for
the accuracy of the model for candidate
input
and these inverse models can make this
substantially easier now an obvious
question that might come to mind is that
i discussed two different techniques
for dealing with this optimism problem
uh the conservative q learning approach
and this inversion approach
could we imagine using something like
cql to address this problem as well
very likely yes in fact that's something
we're working on now i just
unfortunately don't yet have results to
show you
so some concluding remarks um well we
should think about making decisions with
data i think that's a really good idea
and hopefully something many of you are
thinking about
rl already sort of does this but it's
not just an rl problem it crops up
in bandits model based optimization etc
and the issues i think in many cases are
much the same
making decisions with data is really
powerful especially if you can
support big models train on big data
sets and get powerful generalization
um and the techniques in question i
think are going to be very similar for a
bunch of these domains
they basically boil down in many ways to
this issue of distributional shift due
to optimization
and we can imagine constrained
distributions avoiding overestimation
these conservative tricks inversion
tricks etc and many of them are likely
to apply to both domains
all right thank you very much um and i'd
be happy to take any brief questions
okay fantastic uh talk um
so maybe um just uh maybe one quick
question before we move on to the panel
um i don't see anything q ah
maybe a clarifying question for me i
mean the the
plots i saw like your very first plot
where you showed the problem of
overestimation
i saw the value being overestimated but
not the
maximizer it's harder for me to
visualize
yeah yeah so it's you know it's sort of
looking at the at the end result
rather than the intermediate phenomena
so
um the intermediate phenomena is a
little harder to track down because
the q function is conditional right so
it's going to make different predictions
at different states
in some states it might not actually
overestimate uh but
the trouble is that because you're
backing up these values if you
overestimate massively in even one state
that overestimated value then propagates
through the rest of the mdp
so you know as soon as the bad thing
happens in one place it sort of infects
everything else
yeah it'd be nice to somehow visualize
that but yeah i can definitely imagine
yeah yeah we have a little bit more
visualization in the paper in like a
grid world domain
i didn't find it to be quite as
interpretable as this but
you know that maybe would be helpful
okay well thank you again and um let's
uh
let's organize for our panel
and